did you find any
methods to increase one's iq
i read your article but i didn't see any
points about increasing iq per se but
intelligence and that's different
and for the people in the chat
or people who are listening watching
once this is on uh
replay i i find that
people are extremely uncomfortable with
the notion of iq
and they like to point to stephen j
gould
gould who has a critique on iq but his
critique on iq was more about whether or
not iq measures something nebulous
called intelligence
and intelligence like i mentioned is
nebulous or bleary it's not clear
exactly what it is people have different
notions and iq
measures something extremely specific
and iq is correlated highly with
different outcomes in life as well as
the ability to learn quickly whether or
not in
well either way the whole point of that
is to ask did you
learn or did you come across any methods
to increase one's iq
there are obviously ways to decrease it
well if we pull yes
if we pull back the kimono about what
why that article exists
there are people who search the term how
to increase iq
i i've just been i had been thinking
about it independently for a long time
because people on my youtube channel ask
me all the time
how can i increase my iq but one day my
seo came to me which is for people who
don't know internet stuff
is search engine optimization and or
he's a search engine optimization expert
he's on my team
and so i just call him my seo anyway
he says you should do this article on on
iq and i thought ah that's a bit risky a
little bit
you know not as you say not the most um
safe topic necessarily but people are
searching for it
my mission is to reach people who are
searching for things related to memory
so what the hell i'll write about this
and i pretty quickly in that article say
let's change the definition of iq and
then i talk about
goal oriented stuff so the answer is you
know
no i don't necessarily have any ways to
increase iq
but by the same token i think it's worth
the
hypothesis to say if we're going to
increase it what are the ways that we
could increase it
and that article is now still a first
draft
and i we tend to update these things
everything on the internet is beta
i mean video is a bit hard to do after
the fact but in terms of articles and
podcasts
you you're able to just see can we
actually get the people who are
searching for
iq with this i told my seo guy look i'm
not going to do it the way that you told
me to outline it i'm going to do it this
way
and we'll see what happens i haven't
asked them whether it made it to page
one or not
we're pretty good we have 80 20 rule
like everybody else
and get in terms of getting to page one
but i'm
fairly good at it with certain keywords
he throws at me
i don't know what we did with that one
but i thought it was worth a try
because people are searching for it and
what they mean i think
when they say when they put into google
how to increase iq
they mean how do i get smarter right and
so
in terms of how do you get smarter i
think i have included
not only have i got theories and
techniques and strategies for people to
do that
but i think i've got a proven track
record of it i mean we've got
lots of people who have passed exams
that they
didn't dream of passing before they
started to train their memory
and made advancements in learning
languages etc
i'd call that intelligence because if
you can figure out
how to set a goal how to
do what it takes to accomplish that goal
and then properly reward yourself once
it's done
with full modesty then
what else what else would that be other
than having increased your intelligence
i fully acknowledge that it's not
exactly directly addressing
that article uh directly addressing iq
as
the measured thing on those sorts of
tests that has to do with spatial
intelligence or spatial calculation
ability and being able to match certain
dimensional things and then there's
verbal
all that sort of stuff but i think that
we could we could work on it and i think
that memory would be
one of the places that we need to focus
on and raw memory training
i mean it's only it's only 120 years or
something
since ebbinghaus started his very um
n equals one kind of memory experiments
in terms which is i don't know about
that
what is this person's name edding house
ebbing house ebbinghaus hermann
ebbinghaus
and he wrote it's in german uber desk
deschnes which
is basically about memory um
and what he had done is he came up with
the principles of like the forgetting
curve
and he had memorized a bunch of stuff
and he would just test
how long it was before he forgot it and
that led to
concepts like primacy effect and recency
effect serial positioning
effect all of which
i mean if we're going to just talk about
intelligence in sort of straight
language
what else would you call intelligence
other than your ability to remember what
you learned
see it in context in real time be able
to juggle what people are saying
interact with them or whatever a test is
saying and so forth
and um not be destroyed by a forgetting
curve
which is what a lot of people struggle
with within three seconds they'll forget
your name
within you know five days they'll forget
what they read
et cetera and they're struggling with
that so
ebbinghaus was huge and it's we're
really just
at the beginning of memory as a as a
science as a study
and it has historical philosophical
biological chemical neurochemical
dimensions to it that's just waiting to
be
explored